et cet invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
pénélope bagieu bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être sur ce plateau vous êtes autrice
de bandes dessinées dessinatrice on vous
doit entre autres choses la série
féministe culotté sur ses dessins de
femmes exceptionnelles pas forcément
connus ou reconnus du grand public
l'adaptation à du célèbre roman de roald
dahl sacrées sorcières et puis ce livre
sorti il y à peu les strates chez
gallimard on y revient dans un instant
peut-être si vous voulez bien un mot de
politique pour commencer vous avez fait
partie des rares artistes qui s'étaient
engagés publiquement pour soutenir la
candidature de jean-luc mélenchon pour
cette présidentielle ici en france qui
ne s'est pas qualifié bien sûr pour ce
second tour comment vous vivez cet entre
deux tours
comme tout le monde passe pas très bien
je pense avec une certaine angoisse au
ventre pour la suite mais
je trouve que c'était assez j'étais
assez déçu le sort du premier tour
patrick omondi je m'attendais à rien
mais j'étais déçu quand même voilà puis
maintenant j'espère qu'on va réussir à
limiter la casse pour le deuxième tour
il ya ce résultat qui fait que qui fait
peser qu'il fait peser comme scénario
est ce qu'il dit de la france comment
vous vivez avec ça moi je trouve qu'il y
avait en tout cas ce que ça dit la
france de positif c'était un vrai espoir
est un vrai nom notamment de la jeunesse
comme souvent qui avait envie d'autre
chose et qu'il ya des attentes et je
pense que qui va continuer à avoir des
attentes et c'est peut-être ce qui peut
pousser un changement et mettre une
petite pression positive pour la suite
c'est quand même il ya un élan qui s'est
créé de vraies attentes et d'espoir
comment vous expliquer qu'on ait si peu
parlé de culture ou même de création en
général pendant cette campagne alors
encore une fois pas très étonné
je pense que là vraiment la culture est
complètement écrasée par tout le reste
de l'actualité que ça passe complètement
là au dernier plan est effectivement
c'est dommage parce que ça peut être une
réponse à beaucoup de
d'interrogations et de problème mais
mais je comprends aussi que ce soit pas
le souci numéro un des jeux en ce moment
à propos de second tour toute
comparaison s'arrête là ça vous connaît
pénélope bagieu vous venez d'être battu
deux années de suite en finale du grand
prix d'angoulême la prestine la
récompense la plus prestigieuse de la bd
on pourrait on peut se ressent de
recueillir qu'ils étaient trois femmes
en finale c'est pas si souvent pour
autant le grand prix du public là vous
l'avez déjà et depuis un moment comment
est ce que vous vivez votre succès bien
pas de syndrome de l'imposteur c'est
fini ça mais ça toute la vie pour tous
les artistes je pense le syndrome de
l'imposteur mais plus on vieillit plus
on apprend assez bien à travailler avec
et à se dire effectivement il ya des
jours un jour sur deux où je me dirai ce
que c'est ce que je veux que je te vaut
la peine de le faire mais on apprend à
travailler quand même en essayant de ne
pas trop se se parasiter avec ça donc je
vis est bien le succès est bien le
syndrome d'imposture c'est une bonne
chose vous dit quand vous avez commencé
votre blog il ya une quinzaine d'années
qui s'appelait ma vie est tout à fait
fascinante qui a participé à vous faire
connaître qu'il fallait s'excuser de
parler de soi quand on était une femme
est ce que c'est parce que les choses
ont changé que ce livre là les strates
peut exister
non c'est parce que moi j'ai changé
c'est que maintenant je suis un petit
peu vieilli par rapport il ya 15 ans et
que je me pose moins la question de
savoir comment le livre sont accueillis
et si c'est légitime de les faire ou pas
je pense qu'avec le temps j'ai compris
quelque chose que j'aurais bien aimé
avoir compris avant qui était que la
seule chose qui compte c'est est ce que
est ce qu on est contentes pendant qu'on
écrit un livre voilà d'après le même la
suite il faut pas trop y penser il faut
se dire si moi ça m'a fait plaisir
pendant six mois un an deux ans d'écrire
mon livre ce qui vaut la peine d'exister
et puis peu importe en fait ce qui ce
qui dit de moi ou comment il sera
accueilli
strates c'est donc un recueil de petits
moments très intimes de votre enfance
d'adolescence du genre qui marque pour
toute la vie la perte d'un chat le décès
de votre grand-mère les histoires
d'amour une autobiographie dites-vous
qu'il n'avait pas vocation au départ à
être lu quand certains écrivent
dans l'intimité vous vous dessinez
est-ce que ça permet de mettre plus à
distance alors ce qui permet de mettre
plus à distance de toute façon c'est le
temps qui passe c'est à dire que ce que
des anecdotes qui sont assez ancienne et
qui sont des dossiers clos qui sont des
histoires boucle est donc déjà ça ça
aide à ce que ça tourne pas à la
thérapie un peu à vif et pas forcément
très pertinente je trouve
et puis le fait de devoir le dessiner de
toute façon ça oblige à réfléchir à la
mise en scène de ses souvenirs c'est à
dire que c'est souvent ça va être
simplement des des ressentis des
souvenirs un peu brute une ambiance et
de même manière que les souvenirs qu'on
a dans la tête sont rarement
parfaitement rangé et archiver et avec
des mots précis donc je trouve que la
bande dessinée c'est ce qui permet le
plus de venir avec juste est recherché
ces souvenirs la haye les retranscrire
de manière très brut vous dites que des
sujets clos mais vous dites aussi qu'on
passe sa vie et je crois que c'est assez
vrai à détricoter quoi ses souvenirs
d'enfance l'adolescence en tout cas on
passe sa vie à se rendre compte à quel
point peut plus s'en défaire c'est à
dire que ils sont là bas c'est aussi
pour ça que le d'isabelle l'estrade
c'est qu'ils sont là comme vraiment les
couches les plus profondes de la falaise
quoi c'est qui a rien à faire on a beau
essayer d'avancer on il ya des choses
qui nous sont arrivés à 13 ans et demi
qui qui continuent à conditionner ce
qu'on fait tous les jours donc versé
intéressant comme terme strates parce
que pour les voir effectivement pour les
voir sur le rebord d'une falaise il faut
que le paysage sont un peu accidenté
pour qu'elle apparaisse ces strates à ce
titre des explications sans vraiment
très contente décidément beaucoup mieux
que les couches
votre vie et on le sent à la lecture de
ce livre est une vie marquée par les
femmes votre soeur votre maman votre
grand mère aujourd'hui disparus disparus
vous dit que vous avez été élevé de
manière complètement des genres et et
que le traitement particulier qui nous
est réservé à nous les femmes vous
l'avez découvert et vous en parlait dans
ce livre notamment lors des premières
agressions sexuelles qui jalonnent la
vie de toutes les femmes malheureusement
c'est des pages assez terrible
oui alors encore une fois moi j'ai
réussi à les ressortir sans trop de
difficultés parce qu'elle comme vous
dites elles font tellement partie du
quotidien que j'ai l'impression d'avoir
choisi deux ou trois parmi tant d'autres
des micros agressions et des vrais
agression et c'est vrai que ça me
paraissait important de pas les éluder
non plus parce qu'elles font partie de
la même manière que la perte d'un chat
ou où mon bac blanc ça fait partie de ce
qui me constitue aujourd'hui ce qui nous
constitue tout malheureusement et je
pense qu'il faut pas les mettre de côté
comment élever les filles pour que ma
génération soit la dernière à s'être tus
vous dites que vous n'avez pas forcément
la réponse
non mais bon quand même on est comme
pour plein de choses je trouve qu'on est
un peu tirée vers le haut par la
génération qui arrive après la nôtre les
générations qui arrivent après la mienne
en tout cas que je trouve admirable de
pas comment le dire mais deux
de détermination par rapport à ça c'est
à dire que elles n'ont pas un rôle
exemplaire non plus on n'attend pas
d'elle qu'elle sauve le monde mais je
trouve qu'elles font chemin beaucoup
plus vite que nous nous met dans le même
sac
quand je parle avec des lycéennes par
exemple ou avec des jeunes motrices qui
ont 20 ans je me dis que l ont une
maturité qui m'a fallu 20 ans pour avoir
et notamment pour qualifier tout ce qui
est anormal et pour mettre le doigt sur
les choses ou moi c'était tellement
intégré comme normale pendant si
longtemps que je pense que logiquement
quand elles elles auront 40 ans
j'imagine que l on réussit à faire un
peu plus bouger les lignes que ma
génération à moi donc c'est triste pour
elle parce qu'on se repose beaucoup sur
elle comme pour beaucoup de choses on se
repose beaucoup sur la génération qui
arrive en disant qu'ils vont sauver le
monde régler les problèmes de climat et
tout faire mais oui peut-être qu'elle
avait besoin de nous d'une certaine
façon pour arriver là où elles sont
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est un
travail d'équipé c'est à dire je crois
que c'est le reste a name qui dit ça
mais elles elles sont là pour avoir de
l'espoir et a changé le monde et nous on
est là pour être être en colère
culotté et qui sortit en 2016 c'était
sur toutes ces femmes qui n'ont pas
gardé la place qui était la leur ou
qu'on leur avait assigné ça a été
traduit dans une vingtaine de langues un
très grand succès j'imagine que vous
hante en est fier est effectivement
c'était le signe c'est pourquoi ce livre
a tant de succès c'est peut-être parce
que notre génération la vôtre est la
mienne a manqué deux modèles précisément
j'imagine que c'était ça aussi l'idée de
ce livre
l'idée de ce livre c'était de me faire
plaisir en parlant de choses qui
m'intéressent comme d'habitude puisque
c'est toujours très égoïste les raisons
de faire un livre
reste j'ai été agréablement surprise de
l'écho que ça a eu et notamment ce qui a
été le plus surprenant c'est les cox a
eu parmi un public très jeune auquel
j'avais pas forcément accès avant et
auquel j'avais pas du tout pensé en
écrivant d'ailleurs sinon je pense que
j'aurais vraiment écrire autrement si
j'avais su que ça allait atterrir dans
les mains d'enfants de 8 en mai
mais c'est vrai que le retour que j'ai
des enfants est vraiment très je sais
pas comment il fait chaud au coeur à
chaque fois parce que que ce soit des
filles ou des garçons c'est aussi
beaucoup lus par des garçons
eux n'y voit rien de militants se disent
juste trente histoires de personnages un
super cool et ne se ne faut pas
forcément attention au fait que ce sont
des femmes alors que moi au même âge non
seulement je leur ai remarqué
directement je pense mais surtout
j'aurais trouvé j'aurais trouvé que
règne ça c'était déjà remarquable je me
serais dit et en plus elle a fait ça
alors que c'est une femme je pense par
exemple à katia krafft la volcanologues
dont je parle dans mon week end dont je
parle dans les culottes et moi quand
j'étais petit quand je la voyais dans
les volcans avec maurice krafft ce que
je trouve est fou c'est que ce soit et
femmes c'est une femme qu'il aime dans
les volcans et j'imagine que par la
force des choses d'ici deux ou trois
générations ce sera un événement donc
pas sa salle et là la force de cette
génération là c'est qu'elle est presque
des genres et dans le rapport aux choses
en tout cas ya beaucoup encore
d'obstacles bien sûr mais il ya cette
force là parce que vous venez de dire
principal j'espère j'espère que ce sera
plus un suivi j'espère que quand on lira
culte et dans vingt ans on marque quand
même plus que des fous comme on ne
remarque pas quand on lit 30 biographies
d'hommes que ce sont des hommes facile
maintenant heureusement leurs marques
il y aura une suite à un culte et non
parce que j'avais vraiment de penser ça
comme 30 portraits qu'on a divisé en
deux livres mais c'était pas du tout va
être une série c'était 30 pour moi y
avait un début il ya une fin il y avait
une raison si c'était c30 là donc donc
non j'ai fait autre chose après voilà
bien une fois qu'on sait raconter si un
petit manque est ce qu'on fait après
mais je sais pas du tout là pour
l'instant en fait en fait pas grand
chose comme à chaque fois que je finis
un livre après j'attends que ça vous que
ça revienne donc je ne sais pas mais
c'est du temps au temps c'est
merveilleux ça kembo conseil merci
beaucoup merci pénélope bagieu il est
revenu ce matin sur le plateau de parer
direct les strates donc chez gallimard
ça fait du bien de lire ça et puis ça
extrêmement universelle si vous arrivez
merci beaucoup encore très bonne journée
nous on se retrouve juste après la pause
avec damien coquet a tout de suite
[Musique]